mais
m
et
vous êtes inquiète décret pourquoi
est-ce parce que je ne connais pas très
bien ça une grande différence entre un
cinéma là que je connais depuis vingt
ans et la caméra de cinéma nous fait
plus peur depuis longtemps non il ne
s'est pas peur mais est ce que c'est pas
parce que le fa s'est pas bien passé
avec avec certains journalistes de la
presse écrite que vous êtes comme ça oui
parce que vous avez du mal à parler de
vous des rôles vous parce que vous dites
ou dans un film une fois que c'est tout
l'ensemble oui
déjà j'ai beaucoup de mal de parler
primo donne moi même secundo en face
d'une caméra de télévision
parce que le public qui vont gérer mal
de faire une interview j'ai toujours eu
du mal je fais des progrès des petits
mais pas beaucoup parce que le public y
adhérer à la caméra aujourd'hui mon il
ya sept ou huit millions de gens c'est
le public des salles c'est celui qui
vous aime celui qui vient ce coup
d'éclat maintenant ça me fait encore
plus non mais c'est le public qui va qui
va vous voir c'est celui qui va voir en
ce moment une femme à sa fenêtre ou mado
donc c'est un public
vous le connaissez pas à spéculer si je
crois je le connais ce public en france
je crois je le connais parce que ils
n'ont trouvé qu'il m'aime oui mais j'ai
quand même peur mais quand vous tourner
un film
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pendant
tout le tournage est ce que vous vous
remettez en cause est ce que vous vous
relisez le rôle alors que la machine est
déjà en route depuis longtemps est ce
que vous sautez m'a dit que vous étiez
quelqu'un d'assez exceptionnel dans la
mesure où vous remettiez en cause en
permanence tout ce qui se passait autour
de vous je les fais way dans un temps
j'essaie de ne pas le faire mais je n'y
arrive pas c'est à dire de ne plus le
faire mais je n'y arrive pas bien c'est
épuisant nerveusement
oui c'est vrai mais que faire et je ne
peux pas changer ma peau c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous n'allez pas voir ce
que vous appelez dans le jargon du
métier les roches c'est à dire ce qu'on
a tourné dans la journée si oui c'est
les roches la projection j'ai vu
toujours toujours depuis des années des
années j'en étais malade quand je les ai
pas vus et depuis le vieux fusil je
m'efforce de ne plus le voir
et c'est mieux parce que vous trouvez
pas bien je ne suis jamais contente ce
qui me concerne et claude sauter il m'a
viré d'une projection une fois il ya
bien longtemps il a bien raison il m'a
dit ça ne sert à rien que tu vas avoir
la projection que tu vas voir ton
travail tu n'es jamais contente battant
et je suis parti les metteurs en scène
français qui vous ont fait tourner que
j'ai rencontrés m'ont dit que vous étiez
une actrice qui avait besoin d'être
prise en charge complètement par son
metteur en scène ou alors de sortir que
le metteur en scène lui fais une
confiance absolue est ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure exacte c'est ça